fun between us
between you two
um starting with you talking about the
the real estate that you felt you all
were taking up in their heads tell me
what you were thinking about when you
put that tweet out
um I just felt like you know if I won a
championship I wouldn't think about you
know
no other team or what somebody said
months ago I'm gonna be you know
celebrating a championship I'm gonna be
you know happy with my teammates but
as you see after they won the
championship everything was Grizzlies
playing Whoop That Trick on a parade
showing it in the club
talking about Jaren this and that I mean
I feel like you know when you win you
know you can say anything but
I lost it I'ma still be dry at the end
of the day yeah but it's
social media you know they blew it up
like is it beef is it a robbery but no
like those guys can tell you uh even
after you know we lost in a series that
you know I told him I feel like you know
it's time you know for y'all to get
another ring
um you know through Steph clay and
Draymond as well and then they said the
same like you know y'all be back you
know we'll see y'all again it'll be a
lot of fun for years to come but we all
competitors at the end of the day we're
all battling you know in this league to
you know be the best we can be in the
win championships and and that's what
comes with it so
um
so yeah yeah so you're saying after that
series you knew like you said stuff in
them you're like it's time for y'all to
come and get that uh for sure
um honestly I feel like you know coming
out of that series whoever you know it
was was a favorite you know uh to win
the championship and you know with
golden state you know they've been you